we do differentiation last lesson
and so the obvious next step is
integration okay
now
integration of inverse trig functions
properly
it needs integration by parts okay so
this is not integration of inverse trig
functions it's integration that leads to
inverse trig functions okay so let's
start with the statements about
derivatives that we know
for instance
the derivative of sine inverse
do we know by now it's fraction it's
one over
the square root of
when am i gonna learn my lesson and stop
asking you questions like this
okay good now before we move on to that
i want to look at some very common
variants of this okay
dipping into what we know about chain
rule okay so for instance if i slap a
coefficient on the x okay for instance
let's think about inverse sine of ax
okay what difference does it make well
you're going to have the derivative of
the inside right so you've got your a
yes
and then you've got your square root of
one minus
a squared x squared
right
okay now this tends to be well i mean
it's true but it's not all that useful
and it's not particularly neat what
you'll see far more often is when you
put that coefficient
on the denominator now usually you're
like well that would make things
icky or messier wouldn't they but in
this particular case as you'll see in
about 30 seconds
it actually works out quite neatly watch
what's the derivative of the inside
function
one on a i'm going to chuck it in
brackets since i've got fractions and
fractions here right
so therefore i've got this
one minus and i'll have
all of this squared x squared on a
squared won't i
x squared on a squared and now you can
see why that one on a is actually very
useful right it's going to go down to
the denominator number one and then when
it comes inside underneath the square
root sign it's going to become an a
squared isn't it right so that's why
you'll get this a squared and it just
very neatly cancels with the x squared
on a squared okay
so all of these make statements about
integrals they're all derivatives they
all make statements about integrals this
one tells you
color
okay this one tells you that the
integral of one over the square root of
one minus x squared right with respect
to x
is
sine inverse plus
a constant
okay in the same way this one tells you
this
uh sorry wait integral
is sine inverse of x1a
okay so this time going straight to the
integrals right let's think about tan
inverse because that looks a bit
different to scientists doesn't it okay
what would be the integral that i'm
interested in to end up with tan inverse
it's going to be 1 on
1 on 1 plus x squared that's just my
regular one
dx
okay that's going to give me tan inverse
plus a constant
okay now i want you to think for a
second
what if i wanted something like this if
i wanted to take a coefficient into
account and i wanted it to cancel nice
and neatly like i have here okay canon
tell me
why can't i simply say you know have
if i want to end up on this
a squared plus x squared okay with
respect to x
it's not going to be simply chucking a
over a inside here can anyone see why
it's not going to be equal to this
what's the problem why can't i do the
same thing with any rest that i do with
sine inverse
think about what exactly made it cancel
in this case right this one over a goes
on the denominator it's a fraction and
it comes under here and it becomes an a
squared underneath the square root so
perfect okay
aha but when you've got this equivalent
thing for this right it's not going to
become an a squared on the denominator
why not
because there's no square root sign
there to to convert it into an a squared
okay so in order to make it cancel out
nicely like this you need an additional
one over a out the front
okay
if you want i'll prove it to you okay
let's differentiate
one over a tan inverse
x on a okay what's going to happen well
1 over a derivative on the inside
on the top
uh 1 plus x squared on a squared down
the bottom and then of course i have
this constant floating out the front
1 over a okay
that 1 over a and that 1 over a they
become the 1 over a squared and that's
how it cancels
okay are you content with that
now i've done sine inverse i've done 10
inverse i did that very deliberately
because
wake up
those results and those results only
appear on
a table of standard integrals okay now
it's a bit hard to see from there so
when this thing wakes up it will show
you the relevant parts and you'll see
that we've got our um what am i looking
at it just gives you this form
and
this form
is
okay can you see can you see what i'm
looking at
right there in the middle okay so
there's ten of us and there's sign
inverse now there is a conspicuous
absence there isn't there
where's cos inverse
the answer is
cos inverse is there
he's just hiding right
because
when we think about um integration right
and that's what these are they're not
standard derivatives they're standard
integrals okay because they're
indefinite
simple example
right
when you integrate a function you don't
just get one primitive back you get a
whole family right all the guys who are
on top of each other but share the same
gradient because that's what this is
right
so therefore when you think about the
result for sine inverse okay
uh which is uh it's the a one isn't it
so you got this
okay
because you are not just getting one
premise you're getting the whole family
right
because universe is in here he's just
hiding right what does sine inverse look
like
looks like
this
right what does cos inverse look like he
looks like this right but because i've
got the whole family of these guys right
i have this guy
and i have this guy now have a look at
him what's the difference
it's just been it's just been turned
around right
so
comparing this guy and this guy sorry i
think you're thinking about the
difference in these two they're shifted
but think about the difference between
these one is being flipped right in this
case the one i have drawn it's been
flipped
this way horizontally right but if i
choose a different constant for example
if i put him down here
see that
now if i compare this let me put it in a
different color up here
i put him here now he's been flipped
vertically right so i can just as easily
say this is negative
cos inverse just it's a different
constant that's all okay so it's not
that they're being discriminatory it's
that cos inverse really is actually
there okay because the relationship with
the derivatives is so similar okay
so
you need to be very familiar with um i
should circle them for you
this result here
and i didn't even write it on one line
did i this result here
okay which is why they're on your table
of standard integrals okay that's really
more of a um it's kind of a safety
blanket you shouldn't need to look at
those
but you have to be careful they're quite
easy to um to mistake aren't they okay
so be careful